prince harry and meghan markle
uh my favorite couple i think they're my
favorite couple
and the reason that i like
prince harry and meghan markle so much
is that um
they prove
to me that we have a deep need and a
desire for a certain type of celebrity
i don't know where this comes from
it's certainly
uh
something that is
deeply ingrained in our psyche
we want the we like
and love
these types of people
we like high-profile
glossy
uh
people that
are are vapid
and don't have much
going on in their heads but think they
do like they are under the impression
they have big thoughts
big big thoughts
like megan and harry i've listened to
both of them talk
garden variety retards
both of them
she's hot
he's
royal
but garden variety morons either one of
them
just their level of eloquence like i'm
an eloquent person you may hate me many
do
but i'm eloquent
i have a certain amount of intelligence
that i convey with the broadcast twice a
week once here once on patreon i watched
megan and i watched harry
they were using their emotion
to cover up the fact that they were not
smart
they were not
too
smart
and they were obviously it was an
emotionally charged interview
because they had just left the country
uh they had found out that the royal
family is uh racist
which was shocking
um up until now they had only thought
that the the royal family uh had
murdered harry's mother
but upon
finding out that in addition to
murdering harry's mother they were also
quite insensitive on the topic of race
no good
up until that point you said well
they're just an illuminati death cult
that drink blood and live for a thousand
years and have murdered my fiance's
mother
but
we're gonna give them a shot
and let's see how evolved they are and
it turns out they're not too evolved and
i watched the uh oprah interview and we
talked about it on the show they're just
not bright
so like many
people uh but they believe they are
bright
they say the right things they're like
there are so many people in the world
without
yes
there are so many people in the world
without which is why we have to come to
los angeles and live in a
beautiful mansion with round-the-clock
security we got to get a deal at netflix
and make documentaries about people that
are [ __ ]
that's what it is they want to be on
netflix and make documentaries about
people with cleft palates
that's kind of the direction they're
heading in
just like the obamas who got a netflix
deal who should not have no one no
politician should get an overall with
netflix this should be a line in the
sand
nobody they have a production company
too oh well why not yeah they're
probably doing the activist yeah do you
if you doubt for a minute
by the way with no backlash if there was
no backlash meghan markle is on episode
three of the activists
talking about
racial sensitivity training
and the need to do it
you know
or the need to get rid of
horses in central park or whatever pet
cause that episode three happened to be
about
meghan markle would be on talking about
it um
she's a hollywood actress means she's
ambition she has
ambition um actors are stupid people
they're not smart very few of them are
intelligent and the ones that are
intelligent are much much older young
actors are and we know many of them
they're insanely dumb to where it's
noticeable have you ever been with
someone who's so dumb it's noticeable
where you look at someone else as if to
be in disbelief at what this person is
doing
if you had lunch with meghan markle
you'd be stunned at how dumb she was not
cause she's black because i wouldn't
think she was black if i looked at her
because she's an actress who is on the
show suits
okay
she's an actress harry is an idiot he's
an idiot for two reasons number one he
signed up to fight in the afghanistan
war that was a dumb move
you're a [ __ ] prince what are you
doing that [ __ ] for
number two
i know it's heroic i guess after 9 11
but i think he signed up years after
that that's hilarious and number two i
he's still believing this dumb story
that the paparazzi killed his mom maybe
he doesn't maybe just
so she gets them to leave his family she
goes she goes why do we want to stay
here and i get it i'm for them why do we
want to stay here they're racist the
weather sucks the food [ __ ]
let's go to l.a we'll eat sushi by the
pool every day and we'll make
documentaries about people with cleft
palates
he goes well is it when their face is
all yes she goes and then every now and
then we'll fly one of them over we'll
clean up their face and we'll take them
to disneyland but we got to get out of
the uk and we got to come to the usa
we're going to go on oprah and then
every idiot in america but he's like but
they're mad at rich people not our kind
of rich people she goes i'm kind of
black
and you're an idiot
so you just and you're willing to be
emasculated so you just sit there and
eat your own [ __ ] on tv
i'll tell oprah that they were chasing
me around the royal palace with nooses
and then netflix will open up a suitcase
full of money and we'll go do
documentaries about kids with cleft
palates is it like where their lip is in
their nose yes
yes just google it harry
so that's what went on
and i like them i i used to not like
them i've now
i have a new thing now for the holidays
i believe everyone and i love everyone
this is positive me i've been too
cynical for too long but i survived
covet
you know and and other than having seven
or eight skin rashes at any given time
i'm relatively healthy i'm in and norm
just died we're losing people you never
know how long you get so i've decided to
love everyone and embrace i have
embraced uh these two clowns i like them
yes they're grifters yes they're deeply
unserious and they're not that bright
but i respect how far they've gotten
so i am saying yes to them whereas in
the past they would have said no i would
have said no they're exploiting they're
listed oh shut up who cares they're here
and it's fun
watching people fawn over them we like
royalty we love it we like rich people
stop pretending you don't like rich
people
stop pretty the people that tweet about
marxism all day then talk about how much
they love the real housewives you just
can't quit it and nobody is a realer
housewife than meghan markle who married
this ginger [ __ ] and took him out of
his racist family so that they could
live in beverly hills or wherever the
[ __ ] they live and make documentaries
about people without hands
on netflix
netflix by the way who's committed to
just giving these people anything they
want whenever they want they're making a
cartoon what is the cartoon about
it's called pearl yes it's about a young
girl who is inspired by influential
women in history and counts david
furnish and liz garbas among executive
producers
uh yeah i guess that's the
12 year old girl who's inspired by
influential women in history the series
currently in development it's all the
information we have that's it
uh she's on a journey of self-discovery
as she tries to overcome life's daily
challenges says well that sounds great
good for her man do you know how many
actresses
that do a show like suits just get
thrown out in the street
afterwards meghan markle parlayed that
into a [ __ ] royal wedding and then a
year in or a couple of years in said
[ __ ] that [ __ ] and left and i'm not
saying the royal family was not racist
to her i'm sure they were but that also
didn't start
when she got there
they didn't like become racist
she knew like it started probably early
on when they confused her for the help
nine times
they're probably ordering tea from her
an exciting tale that weaves together
fantasy and history pearl focuses on a
young girl who learns to step into her
own power when she embarks on a heroic
adventure and meets important women from
history along the way
we're excited to develop this animated
chairs with our partners at archerwell
productions and story syndicates there
are 12 productions that's that's okay
yeah archwell production so you know
what this is going to be like pearl's
gonna go back you know there's gonna be
a scene
where pearl's like
who are you
my name is harriet
harriet who
harriet tubman
we got a railroad and you go oh my god
this is the underground railroad yes it
is
this is so amazing i can't believe it
you're so brave and strong yes i am
child but i'm not nearly as brave and
strong as meghan markle who's that she
was an actress on suits it's tv show
yeah
she married prince harry
you know the son of that woman they
killed
in a in the thing in the tunnel and they
said the press did it but you know it
was good because she was going to marry
dodie alfayette he was muslim it's a
whole thing it's oil
saudi arabia whatever you got to follow
cynthia mckinney on twitter what
anyway
i'm just
saying yes i'm where's cynthia mckinney
at the met gala by the way that all she
did was took him at 9 11 all day where's
she where is she where is she
well here's what i'm saying child
i'm saying it i may be brave but the
bravest person ever is meghan markle
thank you
i'm excited for that show
i'll never get another special on
anything ever again like
i will i will my special will be on like
pepboys.com
i mean it will be like
it will be so far
every day i hear about like another
executive who genuinely hates me
who like brings me up by name
in meetings that they do not like me
i'm we're selling so many tickets with
this the show's gotten so massive
and uh the offers have been slim
slim to none
but that's okay and then people ask you
to go do you think that's special i go i
don't know maybe i'll do reach out let's
reach out to harry and harry and megan's
let's call my agent right now
on the air
and ask him if he can reach out
let's see if
hey quick question i know it's laid up
you're probably
i figured you're up with a kid is there
any do we think that there's any way
that archer well productions might like
produce my special that's the production
company founded by meghan markle and
prince harry
tweet about that was amazing no but i
mean can we give me a meeting like i
think i should get a meeting with them
i love it why not we should you know
what we should do is we should try over
email and then i'll forward you the
emails and you can post it or whatever
yeah do that do that
you know if folk please
pursue this please all right thank you
brother get some sleep
that's what i like him because he he
he'll get fired too
he doesn't care
you know what i mean
i mean with his clients i mean he could
do his job you know out of a rehab
you could just sit in a
archwell productions i want the duke and
duchess of sussex
do you does anyone
not like this idea though seriously the
duke and duchess of cambridge present
tim dillon
i love it
it's great
we we could do it over there we go
overseas and do it no they're here oh
right right we do it here but they can't
we can't go there anymore because
they're racist right because they're
racist there they came to a country with
no racism america
because the royal family was so racist
they came to a place
where the you know we have the least
racist organization in america right
here in the city the lapd
no no none of this was a plot this was
all well thought out
made sense
is it lo with the clever palette is it
when is it locked a bit in apple but it
got
please google it for him someone
alright
are we going to see oprah
can i meet lizzo
stop asking me questions you're really
[ __ ] annoying me today
okay we're doing it we're doing we're
skyping right now
with uh
the leader of [ __ ]
some country we're about to demolish
for a tv show
archer well productions
these people have me whacked
they'll have me done diana style
they will do me in diana style yeah
they'll whack you